Hello, Dr. Codder's again, section 15, boy, you're just cruising right through this book, aren't you?
All right, so more therapies than I love, so here's one, Leandro B17.
A lot of, if you're old enough, like me to remember all the Leandro fight back in the 70s.
It came out as a huge benefit, cure for cancer, quote-unquote, just a ton of press on it.
The AMA just absolutely slashed to pieces, and basically outlawed the availability of Leandro B17
until, you know, now you could basically warn her about Amazon, but it was outlawed.
In fact, you see very little literature on B17 that isn't from that era.
It is used still in sub-exico-cancer clinics intravenously.
We obviously don't do anything like that, but it's something we recommend a lot with cancer
patients, and we find that it really actually works well. It helps increase the benefits of chemotherapy,
and it will just get into a cancer cell and absorb it to a cancer cell, and can just break up a
cancer cell and kill it. Remember, here's the problem with any of the alternatives therapies.
When you tell them, and when you suggest that they are a cure for cancer, I think that quite honestly,
I do think the FDA should put a stop to that. You may disagree with me there, but I also think
they should put a stop to saying that chemotherapy works on cancer because it doesn't for everybody.
So you can't say that Leandro cures cancer if it doesn't cure every cancer, but I also think you can
say chemotherapy cures cancer. When I have an oncologist tell a cancer patient that they are,
that they are cancer-free, I think that is the biggest disservice that you could do to a patient.
You are never cancer-free. I'm not cancer-free. So it is, you're not cancer-free. You're still,
you're taking a disorder that was likely to kill you and turning it into a product disorder that you
adequately manage. That's that's really what you want to do with cancer. So when you start
saying Leandro cures cancer, I do think that that's wrong. Does Leandro knock down cancer in some people
so that their body can take care of it and that they can live well past their expected life expectancy?
Yes, that's, but in some people. Now in any of these things we're talking about, like Gerson
therapy and the right for the lateral and IP-6 and inside therapy and many other things that we
have in our book have to understand that we don't use all those things. So we test people out and
we might have currently six people on the lateral and 10 people on IP-6 and 20 people on mushrooms and
et cetera, et cetera. So we tested to be specific on what's going to work for them and again,
never do we say we're going to try, we're going to cure cancer. You're not cured anything. You're
trying to increase that person's body's ability to to victory over their current situation because
right now if the cancer's growing out of control, you're losing. So we just want to get you back in
the winning battle. IP-6 is another therapy. You hear very little about it's used widely on the market
that you could buy this on Amazon and there's a lot of studies how it can be very helpful with cancer
and heart disease. It's a great key later. We use IP-6 as a key later of heavy metals quite often
because it's a mild key later. It's just a great product and really probably everybody that has
history of heart disease should be on IP-6. Should every cancer patient be on IP-6? No, I don't believe so
but it can be very helpful for cancer. This is a picture of Dr. William Kelly. He is actually
an orthodontist. I believe he lived in Texas. I read his story many years ago but he had liver
cancer that was turbulent. He was given just a few months to live. His side of his belly was
bulging out. He could actually. He always said it was a benefit. He had the benefit of being able
to visually see the cancer. It was just literally bulging out like a tennis ball and he was given
doe hope. Well, he went to. There was no internet at the time. He went to the local medical school.
I believe it was a Dallas. I might be rough and where it was. It just did a study on what could I do
to help myself with cancer? He came across my Dr. Bard's work. I believe it was from 1905 or 1909
somewhere in that era. We wrote a book on high dose enzymes in cancer and he had done a number
of clinical studies with some amazing results. So Dr. Kelly said, well, what could it hurt? So he
went on a plant-based diet and high dose enzymes and literally he could see his cancer shrink before
his eyes. He just felt better, got better, continued to survive and if he went off of his plant-based
diet or went off his enzymes, he literally could see the cancer just in a day bulge back out. So he
could go back on his diet. He lived another 20-some years after he was given three months to live
and it is church. There was a number of medical doctors that didn't know what to do with their cancer
patients that were dying and saw that Dr. Kelly through diet and through enzyme therapy was
helped so much that they sent secretively a little bit their patients to Dr. Kelly. Well,
he's an orthodontist. He's like, I'm not even a medical doctor. What am I supposed to do? Well,
he's put everybody on the same thing. Well, this is what worked for me. So try it for you. Put
everybody on enzymes in a plant-based diet. And the majority of people did well. It was amazing.
Until, you know, it was I don't know how many months into helping other patients with his
protocol that he had a young woman come to him and putting her on the diet and the enzymes.
She actually got worse. This is where he got into doing what's called metabolic testing. So he
did metabolic typing to find out what your metabolic type is, whether you should be on a plant-based
diet or you should have some meat. He put this woman with a young girl. I believe she was only 19
with terminal cancer. He ended up giving her some meat and then she turned the corner and got better.
Same kind of theory that I spoke about in the previous sections where it can be very beneficial
for a patient to eat meat. So I do not take a dogmatic approach to diet. Some people do better with meat
and there is a whole questionnaire survey that you can fill out called a metabolic typing survey
that you can help understand if you are on, if you sway towards you, do better with eating a little bit
more meat or maybe a lot of meat or you do better eating very little meat or you do better eating
no meat whatsoever at a complete plant-based diet. And all his patients, he used high
pancreatic enzymes doses which were very beneficial and we do that with a lot of patients as well.
It's a great program. His story is quite amazing. Again, he got no credit, got completely slashed,
bashed and banned by the medical establishment. It's it's sorrowful too. It just seems like
everybody that is in this profession goes through just horrific trauma from the establishment. We've been
through it ourselves. I don't expect it to get any better for us. So it's just the way it goes.
But what a beautiful thing that you could help people and you get to heaven. You know you did
the right thing. So that's all accounts. But Dr. Kelly's work is fascinating. Dr. Gonzalez
New York does a lot of Dr. Kelly's work straight. Dr. Kelly's working as a do the testing that we do.
So everybody could have fits into that same protocol. But a wonderful guy as well.
And Dr. Gonzalez has written some books on Dr. Kelly to try to give him credit.
It's just when you're in this profession and you go through what we go through on a daily basis.
I tell you there's not a day that I don't wake up a goal Lord please do I have to go to work.
It is it's it's it's hard when you just get no credit and you get slammed all the time.
But it's beautiful when you're when your patients get better and that's all that I care about. So
that's all that matters. Kelly was one of those things one of those guys and I just
want to honor him as much as I can honor these people that we stand on their shoulders.
So I hope you like this section. And I'll see you at section 16